[Music]
[Music]
welcome to wisdom for life where we sift
through philosophy to find practical
advice that you can use in your everyday
life hi i'm dan hayes and i've got with
me my co-host dr greg sadler today we're
going to talk about
a-i-t-a and if you don't know what that
stands for it's am i the a-hole now
we've been assured by our station
manager that we can actually say the
full word on the error but we're going
to err on the side of caution and just
say a whole and assume that you know
exactly what the a and that refers to we
were actually before that saying
jerk and then jerk hole but the our
station manager said that actually
sounds worse than a-hole so
we're gonna go with that now if you
don't know what a-i-t-h is or aita
rather it's a forum on reddit and it's
got just thousands maybe tens of
thousands of entries of people seeking
advice
about whether they made the right
decision or did the wrong thing
and they're asking for people to make
judgments and we've done a couple shows
on this in the past
and they've you know kind of been a hit
and and i think there's a good reason
why that is um do you i i i end up
seeing them on twitter because i'm on
twitter more than reddit i think you're
more of a reddit guy right dan yeah but
i don't actually subscribe to it okay
just every once will
percolate up but otherwise no
uh and i guess one of the things i want
to kind of like talk about is you know
we're making these um kind of like we're
making judgments right right as one does
you take a a moral um system and you
kind of apply things to it you come up
with judgments from that and it's like
are the the odds
on the show being applied yeah the
show's the odds being applied correctly
in these cases and sometimes we'll will
go from virtue ethics or utilitarian or
you know let's you know a lot of times
we'll talk about this but i didn't want
to make one thing kind of very apparent
is that when we might say
um the at the a-hole yeah
here it's not
that we are now immune that person is
entirely bad that they will forever be
an a-hole we're not casting them into
the outer darkness where there's wailing
and gnashing of teeth
yeah yeah
this is just for this particular action
we're going to make a judgment on that
yeah and these can be really helpful
teaching and learning devices i mean i'm
thinking about using these when i teach
ethics classes
because you know you're right you were
making judgments and a lot of people
don't want to be viewed as making
judgments but the problem isn't making
judgments as such it's the basis on
which we
we
uh you know form them and whether we can
defend them to other people so you and i
might disagree on some of these cases
but you know it doesn't just stop there
we have to try to give reasons i think
this person's a bad person you think
they're you know not a bad person why
you know what what can we offer to each
other right
right and having that open conversation
is uh helpful to understanding how other
people see the world around you yeah you
have a fundamental like disagreement on
some sort of like basis of morality
that's going to make it difficult for
you to potentially agree with them on
your decisions and
it's it's useful to
know
where you can
find common ground based off of
their moral foundations you know i think
another thing that these might be
helpful for is
highlighting consistency you know we
when we're making moral judgments we
want them to be consistent with each
other and the bases that we're making
them so if we're
being very preferential because we i
don't know maybe identify or sympathize
with the people
involved because of our background or
history or something along those lines
maybe our interlocutor can call us on
that and say hey you're uh you're really
hard on this person but you're giving
this person a pass what's going on with
that
right
definitely helps to
sharpen one's own mental tools yeah well
for our audience who may not remember
past episodes do you want to run through
the different options
for
judgments
so we have um
a-hole not the a-hole
no one is the a-hole and everyone is gay
and we could have like a fifth one which
is
we don't know enough you know we're not
quite sure and i suppose we could also
have a
not everybody is the a-hole but a shirt
but a lot of people certainly are right
yeah
right now reddit users actually like
vote on this right they they award what
they call flare which are labels
to say in this case it's been judged
that this person really is the a-hole or
this they're not and the other person is
or everybody is
i think that everybody is is like dark
red if i remember right which is a
fitting color for it
yeah um and
the question is like
is having that type of a form and you're
like voting on these things it's it's
basically a you know a reductio ad
popularium
it's not well
i mean a little bit
there is the possibility and this is one
of the things that i do like about this
format
um it's not just like um
pick one of four options
people
leave comments and in their comments
they they do explain
why they take the position that they
take some of them you know much shorter
than others and some of them also ask
for information and then sometimes
you'll see the original poster giving
information like saying oh well you know
here's here's some clarification about
this
so i it it seems a bit more interactive
than
just like a facebook or twitter poll you
know yeah
um and obviously uh
just so that we have terms um original
poster is the first person that posted
and we'll uh often refer to them as op
right right yeah
you know this is before we jump into
this so
people do get in discussions on twitter
obviously and on facebook and youtube
um
do you think that these reddit like not
all reddit is great i mean some some of
it's a cesspool right
yes but this forum seems to be pretty
good in
general um
would you say even even when people do
are are like clearly the a-hole they're
it's
it's not like they're berating them they
say like here here's my thing yeah
so so is it like a
a teaching tool or something to promote
useful discourse about
moral theory and application
maybe this could be a really powerful
um device right
yeah
i wonder would it be
kosher to actually ask your students
to post something on there oh that's a
good question
you know um
i don't think you could compel them to
right i i suspect that that would go
beyond
there's probably some forums where you
could say yeah put something on
instagram for your artistic stuff or you
know make a little tweet and twitter but
i don't know about venturing into this
forum but i bet a lot of students would
be okay with doing it you know on a
volunteer basis
yeah i i agree that the volunteer is
definitely the
bonus there although the question is
could you give bonus points for doing
that or is that still incentivizing it
well you can you can give extra credit
for anything that you want because it's
extra credit i mean i don't usually give
extra credit to my classes frankly i
usually when students ask for extra
credit i say how about you do the actual
work that i've
thought out ahead of time and given you
because anytime they're asking for extra
credit it's one of two things either
they've already got an a in the class
and they're like some go-getter student
and you're like listen you've already
done enough this is just a class focus
on your other studies right or you know
go go to the gym or take a nap or
something like that or they're a student
who's got a d or an f
and they haven't done the work that
they're supposed to do and then you're
like well why are you why are you
focusing on extra credit when you should
be getting the work that you owe me
already done to to you know at least
some some measure of satisfaction so
but yeah there's no reason why you
couldn't give it as extra credit i think
well we've we've bantered a lot now yes
uh we've basically ate up about one
sixth of our time so we better jump into
an actual case
um do you want you want to read the
first one or you want me to
sure i'll go apart um
am i the a-hole for asking my husband
not to work out in the morning
my husband wakes up at 5am every single
day so that he can exercise before he
starts work
i've never had a problem with it before
however pregnancy has made me an
incredibly light sleeper and also made
sleeping in general difficult i've
gotten to the point where i only get
around two to three hours of sleep every
day because by the time that i finally
fall asleep he wakes up
and wakes me up i asked him if he could
stop working out in the morning he
argued
that the morning was the only time he
could work out because he worked out he
worked all day and couldn't predict when
he would finish he would be had a bad
back and forth about it
and he did everything or and he did
eventually agree but he seems upset over
it and keeps bringing it up and saying
his schedule was ruined
so assuming that everything here is
vertical you know that that it's true
and it hasn't been um
exaggerated that that she's not making
hyperbolic statements
um what do you think
so
first opinion is on
that he
uh she's not the [ __ ] yeah that's um
like you especially one you are living
together with someone you're sharing
space together and you need to
accommodate those people in order to
make sure that they have their basic
needs um i usually consider sleep to be
one of those basic needs otherwise you
know yeah we cease to function quite
well um
now that that's my first opinion
that that's a good point i mean it's
it's not like she's saying oh you're
working out is interfering with me
watching snl at the time that i want to
watch it or something like that you're
right it's a basic need thing
and it sounds like it's not something
that's going to go on forever it's not
like she's saying i needed to change
this for the next 10 years it's just
while she's pregnant
um yeah and it's like i'm looking at
this you know there are other options
for the the man and then uh for the wife
i guess um i also saw like in the second
reading through this i saw a one so the
first thing is you know for the the
gentleman the husband um
is you you can go outside work out um i
don't know exactly what he does to work
out but like i i've lived in apartments
and yeah not doing jumping jacks um in
your apartment over other people it's
usually a good way to maintain your
sanity with your neighbors
um
and and with this with his wife he also
could go to the gym i don't know exactly
what their situation but these are
options that are potentially on the
table and then also the second um thing
is they could set up some way to
change their their sleeping habits to
hopefully get to bed earlier um
just as an aside but it seems like it's
probably easier for the husband to
uh change that than the pregnant wife
yeah it sounds more like he
likes working out in the morning
and he wants to stick to that schedule
because the idea that um he doesn't so
he said that the morning was the only
time he could work out because he worked
all day and couldn't predict when he
would finish well who cares i mean
he finishes at six o'clock he works out
at six o'clock he finishes at eight
o'clock he works out at eight o'clock if
working out is really what's valuable to
him and not working out at the specific
time in the morning this this doesn't
sound like it's that difficult for him
to accommodate
and then you know the so they had a back
and forth about it and then he agreed
but
she says he seems upset and keeps
bringing it up so that's a sign that he
didn't really agree and i think that
you know if if he's not okay with it
then maybe they have to talk it out more
but saying his schedule was ruined
okay that's that's a little i don't i
won't say it's a red flag let's call it
a pink flag right
i mean claiming that your schedule is
ruined because you can't work out in the
morning
it's a little immature right
especially if you're somebody who's
going to be having a kid
i mean
yeah just wait until you got that kid
you're not going to work out you're not
going to do anything on the schedule
that you want to do
so
maybe this is her way of easing him into
that
well that's a good point yeah
[Laughter]
unintentionally i assume yeah
so this one's a pretty straightforward
one i think i mean is he an a-hole
i think he's on the verge of it
what do you think
she will say the first thing is she is
not the angel because she's the one that
is currently asking yeah um
uh
him yeah
he seems a little immature in that
regard so maybe not a not a full-on
a-hole maybe he doesn't meet the
threshold for it no
no
okay well this is this is a good one so
nobody's the a-hole in this case right
but somebody's better and somebody's
worse
right
oh let's let's go to the next one yeah
this is this one's an interesting one
am i the a-hole for telling my step-dad
it's not my job to be a good influence
for his kids
this is the dumbest argument i've ever
had with adults i'm 16 year old female
the steps are 14 year old female 10 year
old male 9 year old female my mom and
their dad have been dating for a little
over a year and are engaged we all just
moved into a new place together because
the parents wanted to blend the families
and no one but them are happy about it
the step the steps and i made an
agreement before they moved in that we
all just leave each other alone because
none of us want new family but if they
need an emergency lift or help with
something when the parents aren't around
that's fine
the aita issue started because i'm a
serious athlete so my lifestyle has to
be pretty healthy i work out a lot and i
meal prep most of my own food to make
sure i keep up with my nutrition plan
the step family have a very different
way of doing things and that's causing
some friction i don't care what shape or
size they are just to throw that in
there it's none of my business but the
stepdad has started using me like an
object lesson to the kids
i you know always eat health really
healthy we should probably be doing that
maybe uh you know she could give some
pointers and we could do a family
gymnast that kind of thing it's really
upsetting the 14 year old especially i
think because she's kind of sensitive
about her size and having me around
isn't helping with it already
over the weekend i was making a shopping
list for meal prep for the week when
stepdad brings in the 14 year old and
says hey stepsis would like to try your
meal plan out can you walk her through
it this is a dumb ask anyway my diet
won't work for her because i spend a lot
of extra calories a day most days and
i'm not a nutritionist to figure out
what she needs but she also looks like
she wants to die on the spot
so i say steps says do you really want
me to do this she says no so i tell her
dad he probably just needs to back off
because this is real sucky for everyone
he says i just think her seeing how you
do things would be a good influence and
i'm like i'm not here to be a good
influence on your kids that's your job
so now i'm in trouble for being
disrespectful and we had to have this
big family meeting about all getting
along and helping each other and i got
more i got in more trouble for telling
them that's rich because they didn't
care what any of us thought about
anything when they were making decisions
but i don't really think any of this is
even helpful like it would be different
if the other kids wanted to get fit it's
still not a job for me but i could try
to do a support so is is this person the
the a-hole
i mean i know who's the a-hole in this
one
so what do you think dan
um i i'm actually a little conflicted
because i i'm looking at the motivations
of each one of these individuals
yeah
um and it
like
i mean we basically have a couple
parties right we have the original
poster
we have the dad and then we have all the
step kids and then we basically have the
from the story non-existent mom who
doesn't seem to be taking any kind of
stand
right and before we go too deep into
this i actually loved this poster um
they definitely have a way with words
and you know i love the the line of um
and she looked like she was gonna die
yep that this is also very much like a
16 year old girl that sounds right
that's perfect
yeah
i mean to me um
i kind of think that
the the other kids
have a genuine beef with their dad
that
you know if if the dad is all about them
like getting in shape and stuff like
that the dad should just like
handle that himself
you know um
the the poster's right that yeah that's
his job it's not just because you get
like sucked into somebody else's family
doesn't mean that suddenly you
especially as a kid have a moral
responsibility to like take over the
parental role
yeah um
i say if he's when he's asking them her
to be specifically a a role model yeah
um i think that's it's an ass too far
yeah um but i also kind of look at it as
okay what what is the father wanting to
do he's his goal here is the betterment
of his children which is a laudable goal
um but you know the road to hell is
paved in good intentions obviously it
seems like the sort of thing though i
mean this nutrition thing is a great
example a lot of parents will um give
essentially give their kids bad
discipline and bad advice about what
they should be eating or not eating
and i mean the the 16 year old here says
listen i'm not a nutritionist i know
what works for me i don't know what
works for these other kids so it seems
like the dad if the dad is really
interested in healthy eating the dad
should be going to a nutritionist
going to some sort of competent
professional
rather than roping his stepdaughter into
it
yeah and it might be that he's just
not aware that he's so woefully
ignorant of of nutrition and whatnot
that like you know before i took my
um what kinesiology course in college i
on
after i took that glass i significantly
changed both my activity as well as my
uh food uh just from getting that little
bit of knowledge and if you don't have
it you're just like well there's food
frozen pizza great you know actually
this reminds me so i was 17 when i first
got into endurance work endurance
lifting right and that meant these um
anywhere from two to four hour workout
sessions with like medium weights very
long um
sets and wraps and i was you know also
working at kentucky fried chicken when
when i was doing that the one that used
to be out by uh the movie theater in
brookfield
and i was i was consuming
at least 6 000 calories every day
mostly like protein you know i would
drink about a get about half a gallon of
milk i you know working at kentucky
fried one of the perks was you know if
there was chicken left over at the end
of the day i could take as much of it as
i wanted so i just take all white you
know like the the breasts and the
the centerpiece and all that and i would
take like 10 pieces home you know and
get home and and i was i was exercising
so much that i would burn through that
you know i also had the high metabolism
of a 17 year old now you know she sounds
like
she's kind of doing something similar
if you've already got kids that are a
little overweight putting them on that
sort of thing man that's going to be
totally counterproductive
right yeah that's one of the things i
picked up your media as well is like
yeah she doesn't know exactly what's
good for them but she definitely knows
that a really high caloric diet for them
when they're not super active is not
going to end up in the uh
ends that the father is looking for
let's zero in on one part of this story
i want to see what you think about this
so
the dad um
wants the younger the younger stepsister
to try the meal plan out and so she
the the older stepsister
asks the other stepsister do you really
want to do this and then
she says no so then the older stepsister
says the dad needs to back off because
this is sucky for everyone
now she gets in trouble for being
disrespectful
do you view that as disrespectful
um
only in the slightest way
but i've
dealt with
my share of your 16 year olds okay
or 15 year olds
i'm like that's par for the course yeah
if you can't like deal with that then
you're not gonna have a good time you
know either uh counseling or raising
kids okay yeah
i i don't see it as disrespectful in
part and i think that this is something
that matters
she didn't create the situation she's
trying to pick like the most diplomatic
way of dealing with what's clearly a bad
situation i think it takes a little bit
of courage on her part to say to the dad
you're messing up here you're creating a
sucky situation that's not helpful i i'm
not telling you what to do i'm just
telling you this isn't working
you know
i just
i don't know if i want to go down to
like tone policing but it just it seems
like it's got some snark to it but maybe
i'm reading into that
yeah well
i'll put it this way there could be an
awful lot more snark
yes
the snark barrel is just barely being
tapped
well let's look at the next one this is
a really interesting one you want to
read this one sure
um i uh 21 year old male am in a long
distance relationship with my girlfriend
also 21
that has been going on for more than a
year now i am planning to move to her
country after i finish college in my own
country
this year i have been excited about this
relationship in the beginning but it
seems like she thinks of me way
differently
she has chronic depression borderline
disorder adhd and
main character syndrome
they aren't very rough
with the symptoms but they do affect us
once or twice a week she has a night
where she wants to isolate herself
because of being depressed where i keep
begging her to just simply talk to me
and that i won't leave her
ever and things like that she doesn't
always listen to me ignores me and just
kind of goes to listen to music until
she feels better boy
i won't blame that
whatever makes her feel better keep in
mind i have depression too but i never
talk about it
on me being depressed every single day i
told her in the beginning of a
relationship that i had depression but
she never really asked me anything about
it
uh
after a month ago
about a month ago she came back tired
from work and she called me and said
hello
in a sad tone
because i was depressed the time she
immediately lashed out at me saying that
i am the a-hole to hear her having a
happy tone and that i'm trying to put
her down and make her sad because i
sounded depressed
so i just said i'm sorry i'm depressed
and asked her to help me feel better so
we have fun together
she hung up on me
when she heard that she didn't contact
me again that day but in the message
saying if you're depressed and i'm happy
act like you are happy because it's rare
that i'm happy
after we made up she keeps making fun of
me for having said i am depressed and
that i really don't have anything to be
depressed about and that instead we
should focus on making her life better i
just kept my mouth shut because i didn't
want to say anything that will not be
nice to her am i the a-hole for asking
her to help me over
just one time when i showed my
depression
self to her even though i know she's
usually depressed
so
um
clearly a codependent couple right um
a-holes i mean
i
i think her behavior is a-holish
um
but i also think that this is um
i don't know this is this is one of
those things where clearly people um
don't have coping skills that they ought
to have or communication skills and
they've gotten themselves into
sort of the real they're reinforcing
each other's stuff here um
so yes
i mean i think there's a lot of red
flags here um
yeah i would
agree um they are awash it feels like
it's a you know a soviet parade here
on
with missiles and tanks
hi
um
and
yes this is what comes down to at least
uh one of the things i find kind of
a difficulty with in our culture for men
that it's not
unusually
uh
acceptable for men to talk about like
mental health things
um
yeah there could be some way there could
be some like gender inequality here i
mean i see it more as like she being
unfair and perhaps narcissistic in in
relation to him
um but yeah i mean maybe maybe it does
have to do with that i mean she's making
fun of him that's i think right and
that's one of the things that's like the
worst like the cherry on the cake of
like this being bad yeah especially like
opening up and trying to like hey this
is someone that you obsessively care for
if not love um
why would you ever um
put someone down for for opening up and
trying to make that connection with you
yeah
you know another thing
this it's as if her
problems
are the only ones that can be
genuine problems there's only enough
room
in the relationship for one person to be
depressed
right that that's a bad sign right there
because then he has to keep it to
himself and and she's telling him you
know just quite frankly
if you are depressed that i'm happy act
like you're happy right so
that's so yeah
um and another thing about this is in
the very beginning that they're trying
to kind of er i guess he's loading us
with um preconceptions before we
actually uh look at her actions okay and
so he says specifically that she
uh has chronic depression borderline
personality disorder adhd and main
character i'm not sure what that is
right that last one i'm like okay um
yeah but uh the question is is he just
making those assumptions is main
character syndrome like uh like i'm the
only one that cares yeah yeah maybe
that's what it's referring to um yeah
just what you were talking about just
before now
yeah i didn't put all the words together
i was like mane and character
what what the hell is that okay main
character makes sense yeah yes yes
um but i don't know if these are like
actually diagnosed
things that he said i mean that's a big
problem is people throw these sorts of
words around adhd especially you know
people who don't have adhd are like i'm
adhd today you know and you're like no
you're not suffering with real adhd
that's that looks like this you know
borderline personality that's that's a
big diagnosis if you've got that i mean
depression
okay you can be mildly depressed uh
moderately depressed severely depressed
i'm i'm i'm fully depressed well
clinical is all of them you know oh yeah
those are all just diagnoses i'm i have
a diagnosis of mild depression i've had
it since i was uh a teen
um doesn't mean that you can't like
function now if you're severely
depressed those are the people i can't
get out of bed you know
um and then you know you got moderate
depression in the middle
so we don't we don't know i mean chronic
depression just means that it it lasts
it's not acute it lasts over time right
but borderline saying that somebody's
got borderline personality disorder
that you really have to have a
psychiatric diagnosis for that you know
so and but the question is we don't have
enough information here yeah i don't
know if these are just the things that
he says or the things that she says
about herself right or the things that
are actually been diagnosed about her
um
yeah
yeah
let's go either way so let's say
she's got everything that he's claiming
and um
this is the way that she behaves i would
say she's still acting like an a-hole
i would agree
so
yeah
now is he in any way acting like an
a-hole
maybe to himself
you know
yeah
um
so it definitely seems like he's he's
having questions so that's
so that's good actually right yeah
yeah
i mean maybe he's reaching out and
saying sort of something along the lines
of is this normal you know is this the
relationships work you know um
yeah that would be good
i put down my my note here run
yeah
yeah i mean
i've had my share of relationships with
people in the past who like came
straight out and they're like yeah i'm
i've got lots of things wrong with me
and you know you can you can kind of
you know you can be nice and and say oh
well we'll deal with it together and it
almost never works out you know i mean
there there are times when you find
things over time and people are
genuinely trying to work through them
but when they're really really upfront
with
psychiatric diagnosis language i think
that's usually a bad sign
yeah i'd
i thought you agree there i mean it's
one thing if somebody says listen you
know i'm in aa because
i've got some problems i'll always be an
alcoholic don't let me drink
you know but they're they're cool
otherwise right
um so another thing if somebody says oh
i've got this laundry list of stuff
that's wrong with me and i i i'm the
only one who gets to to be suffering in
the relationship you know you have to i
think that the second thing is the big
thing is like i'm aware of these things
and i'm working on them and i'm happy
for you to help me with them
um
versus uh yeah this is just an excuse
for all of my actions which it shouldn't
be right right yeah that's that's a good
way to put it
well let's let's look at the next one um
this is this is a funny one
um
am i the a-hole for asking the principal
about why she was fired at her last job
my two sons go to elementary school the
old principal was great he is respected
and liked the kids were crazy about him
he took a promotion and left last year
they brought in a new principle and i
personally got this unlikable vibe from
her she just wasn't personal with the
parents or kids the kids seemed
indifferent or scared of her i tried to
talk to her and she blew me off things
don't run as efficiently or effectively
as before whatever my kids are third and
fifth graders so they're not going to be
there long over the course of the year i
saw a lot of the old staff disappear and
a new person like every other month
my eldest son has aspergers and adhd so
he has an aide who'd been with him since
kindergarten he told me he was going to
be leaving next week i assumed he must
have found another job he said he
couldn't stand working with a new
principal and that explains the turnover
and a lot of the teachers are jumping
ship it made sense i was pretty pissed
about his leaving though
i asked to speak with her for 15 to 20
minutes today before meeting with her i
looked her up and she had gotten fired
from another school district you really
have to mess up to be fired i told her
as a dad as a member of the community as
someone who cares about the school i was
concerned about her leadership good
people leaving left and right i told her
she doesn't seem like she's fitting in
she told me she was doing the best job
she could do and then i asked her why
she was fired from her last job after
less than a year she was taken aback and
told me that our district thought she
was qualified i countered that so did
the one that fired her i told her i
wasn't trying to be a dick as a
stakeholder i'm alarmed at what i'm
seeing as a principal she ought to be
able to
deal with that
so is he the a-hole um is anybody the
a-hole in this what do you think
so the first thing comes to mind is a
question of of privacy and
um is there some expectation of privacy
there or in terms of firing and stuff
like that
yeah i don't know exactly how he
got a hold of this information but he
figured it out yeah um and so it's kind
of like you go on a date and someone's
looked you up yeah yeah which that's
gonna be at least right yeah yeah um but
it's it's a little bit
unnerving when you're you're meeting
someone and they know stuff about you
that you never told them yeah
um and now you're like especially if
it's new it's like you know if you're
like you your friends or your family you
know like people and like oh did you
hear about like bob did like that last
week yeah it was very cool okay yeah
like
there's definitely
a feeling that comes over you when you
know that someone knows more about you
than you know about them yeah um
but
is it a whole material um i've been
feeling
kind of known especially because like
this is a person that is materially
impacting the well-being of at least one
of his children you know and in this
case it's a leadership position and i
think that we probably have to have
different
ways of looking at this for people in
leadership positions if you're a
principal a superintendent you're you're
at the top you know it's sort of like
vetting um a c-suite executive
you know you don't expect
maybe maybe the c-suite executive isn't
isn't entitled to the same amount of
privacy as a manager
is let alone an employee
that's that's i think that's the way i
would look at it
um especially if it's going to you know
it's not just affecting him
he does have a kid that he's worried
about but
it looks like there's a larger problem
you know if he's if he's being truthful
right
and and i don't think there's any reason
to think he's he's not being
um i mean if he if he isn't being
truthful and he's making this stuff up
this this guy's really got an axe to
grind
right
um
so i say not the a-hole um and
uh
i guess i wouldn't be totally
saying that she should not be taken
aback
um
yeah and she doesn't seem like she's an
a-hole in this i mean maybe
maybe she is in other ways this part of
the background but
when it comes to like being taken aback
by it i don't think that makes her a bad
person
no
i think that's it's kind of a natural
reaction there
yeah
um
i mean let's think about how this would
play out in other
venues
um
so you know we mentioned corporations if
you're
a higher level level executive maybe you
don't get as much privacy you know like
people could ask you um
other stakeholders could say why
why did you leave this other company you
know or why did they let you go
that that might make sense i mean
usually who who gets the brunt of this
it's the employees it's not the
higher level executives they're the ones
who tend to get a pass
what if it was in the military you know
would we should we say that like
you know officers should face more
scrutiny than enlisted people i'd i'd be
cool with that
you know yeah
i'd agree um what would be some other
uh
venues well the the natural is
politicians right oh right yeah yeah
good example yeah cause like uh we're
talking about our
you know a school board versus you know
the governor yeah yeah people are gonna
want to know who their governor is
people still want to know who their the
school board people are but it's not as
many people and it's not nearly as
in-depth
you're not gonna like pay someone a
private investigator you know a couple
grand to go dig into a school board
member for the most part but you might
do that for a governor yeah that that
makes sense yeah
um so politicians
sports figures um i mean it really
depends on who the figure is doesn't it
right
i guess if you're looking at like people
in the oh that is interesting
um
i mean a lot of people on professional
teams are not really that well noticed
they kind of just fly under the radar
because they're yeah they're you know
like in football they're the offense of
a defensive line or something like that
right compared to the quarterback or the
star wide receiver or
you know somebody who sticks out like a
kicker
or a long snapper yeah yeah yeah
uh yeah yeah the anyone who becomes like
the face of a franchise
okay you know tends to get that the
scrutiny whereas like everyone else is
you know
you know i guess it comes with the the
rewards if your face is franchise you're
also probably being paid quite well both
for you know your actual physical
abilities on the field as well as for
endorsements
and if you also you know go around you
know hitting your girlfriends
then
all of a sudden that scrutiny is going
to you know backbone certainly has been
a problem in the nfl you know or you
know in the 1990s
dogfighting well well there was that
that was like the 2000s but i'm thinking
about the packers and and you know
scandals with underage uh girls you know
oh yeah uh mark chamura yeah yeah i mean
um
uh you know my sister worked in a pool
hall in the up up in the uh
fox cities it was a really you know
high-end kind of place and the packers
would come in
and back then when the packers would
come in people would just leave
because they're like these guys are
trouble you know so
uh yeah maybe and maybe we can go back
to the general principle being if you're
getting higher rewards and you have more
potential to screw things up maybe you
deserve more scrutiny you know yeah so i
agree yeah uh
all right let's move on let's look yeah
this is this this one's a doozy as well
um
you want to read this one
um okay yes um am i the a-hole for
asking my boyfriend to stop going to his
deceased ex-girlfriend's family's
house
so
my boyfriend's ex passed away five years
ago he does not go over to visit her
family as he isn't close to them
but he goes over to walk slash hike and
spend time with her dog
i can't go because she's
uh reactive towards humans and he just
wants to spend time with the dog i feel
as though the dog will be fine without
seeing him
her family can take care of the dog
he says i'm the a-hole because he knows
she would want him to be a part of her
dog's life still because the dog was
really important to her
but he also does this on his only days
off taking time from our relationship
i may be the a-hole because he wants to
go there
edit to add some more information he
spends thousands of
dollars every year on the dog money we
don't have for the dog that spills toys
bedding treats anything it needs it
doesn't or doesn't need it gets it
i feel as though this is her family's
responsibility and not his
so
i think he's an a-hole uh frankly yeah
um yeah i mean
this
you know
this is the sort of thing
where
there's there's a couple different
things i mean she points out that he's
spending money right so there's there's
time there's money there's affection
and i don't want to say the dogs should
be deprived of any of these things but
it sounds as if there's already people
there to provide
these things the family the family of
the person who
um who died and who are related to that
person
so you know and this is this is her
boyfriend's
ex not it's not like she died
while they were still going out
apparently right
so that's a little weird um
uh in my view i guess that's not how i
read it but
it could be that
do you i mean you think it's more like
my boyfriend's
uh what would you call it i mean he's
like a widower essentially but not yeah
i i don't know i guess that's the way i
was reading it okay and yeah
and so it was i was reading it more
along the lines of him
grieving
and
like i've
had family members who have lost loved
ones yeah and they have they they love
that damn pet yeah yeah
um
because it's the last thing that they
have that's like directly connected to
them um now like my initial thought at
least coming from that perspective
is he could probably use some therapy to
go through whatever is getting him
especially if he's he's spending so much
money on this dog it seems
abnormal and i'm trying to understand
why the heck he's making these decisions
i mean five years that's a long time
um and i would think it would be
different if it was like he misses his
mom
and or he misses his great uncle and
this great uncle had a dog or something
like that but this is a case where he's
he's he's moved on to have a girlfriend
right so he's cool with that
but he hasn't let go this previous
relationship which is being mediated
through an animal an animal that doesn't
doesn't know about this stuff i mean the
animal's probably forgotten about his ex
anyway five years is a pretty long
horizon you know
i'm i'm not quite sure the length of the
timelines that a dog can remember uh
their previous owner it's not like
anything's going to spark that memory
because she's not going to come back to
life and you know walk through the door
and whistle and you know
rover comes trotting out and is oh i
missed you or anything like that right
yeah i think the biggest thing is um
that he
you know as you said in the very
beginning that he is you know uh
giving especially
monetarily the things that he does not
have
um yeah you know as well as you know
there is a large amount of time like in
a relationship i know you'll be in a
relationship with you know multiple
people working it sometimes can get
really hard to have time with each other
right right yeah um and it's it's sort
of a question of like well who do you
owe
the
limited amount that you you have
to i mean if
if all things if she wasn't in the
picture maybe it would be fine for him
to be doing this right because he's he's
like a
single guy and this is how he remembers
the love of his life and you know like
she says he doesn't even like hang out
with the family it's just the dog you
know um
but since he is involved with somebody
in a committed relationship as as we
assume
i think he has a greater duty to spend
the time and the affection and the money
on her rather than the dog
which kind of sucks for the dog but but
it's not as if he's abandoning it you
know he's taking it to a shelter and
saying
goodbye rover hope somebody finds you i
mean it's got a family so
and
and
i've been looking at this like you know
once again my original
reading is that he's still grieving okay
uh and and for that
it makes sense why he's doing these
things
um
if it's not that
then and it's just the dog then yeah
totally
i mean this this brings up an
interesting point though um
i mean this is this is something that
like you know seneca talks about
in relation to grief and seneca differs
from the other stoics the other stoic
said ah you know
feeling grief is not a good thing you
you can you know so like act like you're
grieving to commiserate with somebody
but it's it's not a good thing and
seneca says no no there's a point to it
but you should be reasonable in how you
grieve right and so we can ask about
duration
and weird quirks and stuff like that if
if
if i'm grieving through an animal five
years after
uh
my spouse dies
i don't know that that's
that's kind of self-indulgent i think
and i'm now kind of moving away from my
original position that's because okay
like i said earlier
that um even though you have these
issues it does not
give you it can under explain why you're
doing them yeah it still doesn't give
you
the ability to be right and doing these
things that are not
good for like the obligations that you
have so he he's set up that he has this
obligation because he's in a
relationship and there are certain
obligations that are
needed in order to maintain that
relationship yeah yes failing at meeting
those at the moment
um because of this thing that he has a
hangout
there is one thing to say about that
though um
she doesn't say that he's like
increased the time or money that he's
spending so it sounds like she got into
this relationship with him
while he's doing these things
so that's a little strange i mean did
she think that he was just gonna like
snap out of it or move on eventually i i
don't
i don't see her saying that you know
yeah
uh
these are some of those things like how
could i ask a question yeah and on the
board you could actually do that yeah
um so let's move on i'd say okay
so
am i the a-hole for telling my aunt she
deserved it after my mom quote scammed
her
now this is a uh
an interesting one i know this might be
confusing from the title but i will try
my best to explain it my
uh
my i'm an 18 year old uh male my mom 52
year old female last year had an idea to
start a small business my mom told my
aunt 50 year old female about this idea
and my aunt gave my mom quite a large
amount of money as an investment in
exchange my mom agreed to give my aunt
some of the profits my mom's business is
mainly about buying stuff for cheap
online and she sells them to people in
our neighborhood my mom mostly sells
things like phone cases laptop cases
mugs etc
they have a lot of different patterns
like cool designs or characters from
cartoons on them so they look very nice
and people in our neighborhood became
began buying them from my mom my mom
orders them in bulk and makes a 50
profit by selling them but the thing is
my mom hasn't told anyone she's buying
them online
everyone knows my mom is the one adding
these patterns nobody knew nobody except
my aunt knew the truth
so my mom's business exploded she'd
gotten a lot of customers and we can't
began making a good amount of money my
mom wanted to pay my aunt back the money
she gave her but my aunt was a little
busy and she told my mom she'll take it
later
recently my mom and my aunt got into an
argument they've had arguments in the
past and i thought things will get
normal again but they didn't i won't go
into detail but it was because my aunt
accused my mom of doing something which
she did this turned my mom's family
against her and now my mom is not
speaking to my aunt or my grandma
i thought they were going to keep this
between them my mom was going to pay
back my aunt the money she owed her but
then my aunt did something and took it
way too far my aunt made a post in a
facebook group of our neighborhood
pointing out how my mom was quote
scamming people she she showed the
website my mom was buying the stuff she
sold from and this news spread quickly
and my mom's business went bust
my mom eventually got to know about this
when my aunt asked her for the money she
owed her my mom refused to give it back
that made my aunt mad at my mom and she
called telling me about this and said my
mom was a
[ __ ] for not giving her money back she
told me to tell my mom to pay her back
but i said i couldn't do that because i
don't want to damage my relationship
with my mom by siding with her
she kept telling me how wrong my mom was
doing and this made me mad because i
felt like she was trying to guilt-trip
me so i just told her no and and that
she deserved to be paid back nothing
after what she did to my mom
then she began saying my mom manipulated
me to side with her and called me and my
mom a-holes but i wasn't listening to
any of this and i hung up on her i
haven't heard from her since that
i don't think what my mom did was
scamming people it was just business i
think my aunt took it too far and
honestly i don't blame my mom for being
upset and not paying her back so my
question is
am i the a-hole for this
um
eop
my opinion is
no
yeah i think that's right
um
now
do you think anybody else is the the
a-hole in this case yes okay
everyone else
or at least the the other the the mother
and the aunt you think you think your
mom is okay oh yeah so the on i don't
have any problem thinking that she's any
whole what she did you know to
deliberately just destroy the business
and then demand the money back that's uh
that's
really over the line why do you think
the mom is though
um
because i'm not convinced of that
okay there's i just want to double check
on one thing
um i guess
so
i mean we get into a conversation right
would be she she should have paid her
back right
or she shouldn't be
selling things in that way
um that's basically
i those are the two places where i think
you could you could go after the mom
yeah and so
well the first thing is yes that there's
a um
you know a lie that she allowed to
propagate in order for her to
maintain this business
um
and
you know
like you're just saying this business
um
it's like oh well it makes money so that
like
abdicates you for not uh absolves you
from
um you know doing unscrupulous things
and
i don't agree with that yeah
and
so i guess i guess the way it reads and
i think it's like maybe it's it's
mis-expressed here um
the people in the neighborhood thinks
that his mom is the one creating the
patterns right that's the issue yeah
okay um and so i don't know
how that started but
um it seems like she was quite happy to
let that
mistruth propagate yeah and her real
financial benefit okay so there's
definitely some deception there so that
that's some you know a hillary yeah
going on
um and then
uh
did she actually make profit here
um and because she does say that like
she was able to pay the her back
that she had made enough money to pay
her back yeah and so at that point in
times like okay um i assume that you've
then that was a while ago so you were
making more money so you made enough
money to pay back your initial
investment as well as to make something
more
you're already up and uh just because
someone called you out on your lie yeah
on i mean she couldn't
she could have been sinking that into
buying more uh stuff though right
i mean we don't we don't know that but
yeah but once again the whole business
is based on
a you know if not an explicit lie uh an
implicit one so it's an a whole business
model you could say right
right
so i feel like there's a holy to go
around
yeah i mean um
it's it's an interesting one i mean
these a lot of these i think this will
probably be the last one that we'll have
time to talk about a lot of these show
just how easy it is
for relationships to go off kilter when
people are
you know they're kind of playing fast
and loose with what they ought to do you
know
right
and like i think the biggest thing is
like
i'm much more
willing to go and support a a small
business or an artist especially if i
know that they're making the product
yeah but if they're just like someone
that's reselling stuff it's like that's
like a drop seller it's like yeah you're
you're not doing much of a service there
yeah it's and
you're just showing that you can like
click websites and
i mean there is the well i'm a middle
person
you know i'm getting stuff to you that
looks pretty i mean so she'd been
upfront about it
yeah yeah although i have no problem
with it if she had been upfront about it
anybody could have gone to that website
and cut her out
well it might be that you need to buy
things from bulk and so that that makes
perfect sense okay that's the reason why
stores exist you know you you buy it at
one price and you sell at retail true
yeah yeah so that that's a good point
so um
before we end with our final thoughts
any other things you want to say about
any of these cases or
um
we can all
be an a-hole sometimes just try to
reduce it
that's a good point yeah well do you
want to lead us out on uh some final
final thoughts yeah today we will leave
you with the words of william gibson
before you diagnose yourself with
depression or low self-esteem first make
sure that you are not in fact
surrounded by a-holes
[Music]
you